I want I want her to have no allergies
ooh that's a good one when your partner
has bad allergies you also technically
have them in the way that like you have
to look out for everything they need to
look out n has allergies is so annoying
yeah like peanuts got to be off
everything you can't eat at certain
places you know they they can do that
one thing where like one eye looks over
here and the other one can see what's
going on over
there why for surveillance for
surveillance this is trying to create a
[Music]
welcome back to a sixth episode of
careful boys we got to do another a
recer we're yes that's you keep jacking
Jack yeah get it get it get it get it
all right they're done sick all right so
um Steve was just me and Steve was just
talking Steve was like man I hate
checking in with people on these off
records and stuff so we're not done
checking we're going to do what what is
that a mental health check in and Nick's
not even here yeah we're just sick of it
we we only want to focus on Nick anyway
so that being said including how come
you guys never ask me if I'm off myself
if you're going to what how come you
guys never asked me if I'm off myself
because we know you love yourself too
much God you're so right besides we
checked in last night so that's true
okay so this OTR prompt all right sick
super sick including cleen all of us
here together and we have to agree are
going to describe the Perfect Mate looks
body beliefs lifestyle religion
everything divert from my actual mate we
have to agree so I know I know that
you're the [__] Oddball out but all
of us have to construct the perfect for
us individually or for us as aou as a
group for the group it has to be a
harodite then yeah like what am I going
to get out no she's a careful boy no I
understand that penis in a unique spot
though we have to agree she needs a
penis but we need a vagina a detachable
one we don't do this [__] we're just
going to describe our chicks and like
it's another eye roll video how about
two yeah how about two versions one
version for me with you guys and a
version with you guys and for you so you
want us to describe the perfect guy wait
so we have to collaborate on this
Frankenstein so we're just we're
basically throwing traits into a
cauldron yes but we all have to agree if
we don't we'll say gay [__] about our
chicks and stuff I know all right um
wait I'm sorry they have to be
nice uh I don't know about that well cuz
bar was saying or we were saying earlier
that Roseman Pike is hot cuz she's kind
of icy yeah Icy Hot yeah but ultimate
she's nice but you're saying a mate
right so like someone going to try to
spend some time with long it's a really
funny prompt I like it how about a mate
and just a hookup okay would that be
different let's let's start easy let's
start basic what size no how about this
can we just go one at a time and we just
add so I'll start oh that's cool all
right mine I want webbed feet okay what
the fu because you could swim you could
swim better sabotage but is this
individually or for the group group
water people I don't want that you're
starting nuts no this is what we think
the group is going to we can't start
with nuts Bart no you can you can
petition you can make yeah you have to
State your case we're just going to
either accept or deny okay got it so
it's okay denied all right go ahead talk
us into it why okay I I like to build
situations from the ground up I like to
start with with the toast I like to
start from survival right before you
build the house maybe you should have a
fire extinguisher before you even start
laying 2x4s in case it catches on fire
right I'm with you so far I'm with you
so with survival you want someone that
can swim and right now our toes are
lacking some webbings so if we can have
some webbings then you know if [__] hits
the fan your mate can swim really well
but you live in Las Vegas in the desert
okay okay okay to be fair in collabor in
the spirit of collaboration I'm down for
one webbed foot I like to travel too
think that's unique I can't have freaky
feet yeah if she has one she's just
going to be spitting in a circle so so
vote ready uh all for denial raise your
hand deny I tried I tried deny I tried I
my friend
um so normal fee
deny wrong you
[__] she's like penis penis
penis yeah yeah penis what denied denied
you don't get to have a penis on for
this one for the first
model democracy is so sick yeah Den all
right fine physically
athletic okay we'll take it come on come
approve approve
approve generally yeah approve okay go
ahead Steve but not a powerlifter girl
they're kind of fat big ass
[__] titties
oh how big are we talking about just got
overruled ding ding ding hey no I'm for
it oh hey yeah denote the size denote
the size can be baby and how many how
many big as can be no as many that can
fit no that's too big she just got a
ring of tit she got like three tit e so
so far we got a athletic chick with big
titties nice we're winning so far okay
okay okay good content all right oh this
is a girl we didn't even say that gender
we starting well I'm imagining a we'll
sum it up at the end and fight we'll
figure it out I have I have a feeling
about it I don't know we'll see we'll
see how the vote
goes I think I'm a little outnumbered
here all right Anthony sings Like An
Angel oh oh yeah accepted yeah why not
being able to sing is nice being able to
sing is nice good but she could be
annoying about it like sing all the
[__] time and then and then we always
go to karaoke be sing like a devil she
goes to karaoke to show up like those
trans girls denied you know the trans in
those trans
songs but she's so full of herself sing
like an angel like she sings good
morning yeah she's like let's go to
karaoke again let's be optimistic okay I
like the huge tits big as can be as many
as possible and she sings good singing
like an angel with a normal foot yeah
let's go I want it to be like Snow White
where she's singing in the forest that's
your trait that you're throwing in no
he's I think he's just adding on to the
singing
yeah you ever been with a chick who did
who did like musicals
though n not that kind that's not an
angel I think Snow White would look at
the musical kids like y'all weird cuz
she's naturally in the forest singing
never okay Anthony that was my thing
just singing like an angel go
ahead
um has
a
very Carefree spirit
I like that but how Carefree like where
she puts you in danger she like you
where she just car cares freees too
much denied all right how about this how
about this how about this person you got
to put a percentage on it yeah okay this
[Laughter]
person uh doesn't get caught up with
little things oh yeah so she's not a
woman well I thought it was a
woman's winning how about I'll just make
it easier likes to travel likes to
travel okay I like that enjoys traveling
all right all right see enjoys yeah okay
cuz we all travel differently but likes
to doing it yeah that's true that's true
likes to doing it yeah likes to doing it
likes to doing the travels uh has a dark
humor absolutely got yeah yeah this is a
good one I like that one accept all
right a funny
on their body's like web fingers a
monkey tail for
survival in the desert all right I'm
going to throw mine away because you
guys don't like it big dorsal fin I was
going to say can hold her breath for a
long time but I'm no do that no that's
that's useful that could be Advantage
sexual hold her breath for 3 minutes I
don't think that's what he means that's
genderless I'm why not yeah wait 3
minutes I say five I bump it up to five
3 minute cab it's weird if it's F yeah
but if she's sucking your dick upside
down cuz you're doing a standing 69 she
could suck suck without breathing breath
through the nose through those moves
want that one you can do that for five
no but I'm I know some Filipinos that
can there was a documentary about this
tribe minutes minutes 5 minutes it could
be guy or girl you know specifically for
upside down 69s there it is correct all
right for colen this man can hold his
breath eating you out okay I think I I
figured that out would you have to hold
you knew that I just had to paint the
picture she's quick um Talk story movies
you want him to talk you like that I'm
just [__] with you guys now not no no
not noen come on give us a serious one
don't mess with the prompt dude no give
us a Ser no give us a serious give us a
serious one hey a lot of the stuff that
we mentioned are it's genderless you can
it's good with business it's business
business minded okay bued
help no what I want to be the one that
[__] teaches a I'm just kidding no no
I do actually it would help a lot it
would help a lot all for it raise your
hand business yep business not the
pleasure I don't know [__] business y it
would help yeah I don't want to work
good at business not the pleasure big
old [__] ass yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah big ass yeah
isn't that good for a guy or girl you
want that for a guy big
old some guys have really nice butts big
old booty I hate this [__] you want a
guy's ass busting out of those Jord
dases no not like busting out bar has a
pretty big ass though yeah bar got a big
old is that too big oh stand up big old
boy right there let's see them on those
butt cheeks yeah no it's
fine he did the Nacho Libre Flex he
didn't even really go all out it's not
busted uh okay when he's wearing shorts
he's eating those shorts up yeah all
right so it's a big butt big tited good
business F we are making a man what we
don't know that yet don't know yet we
don't know that hella is huge tits we
said tit they could be pectorals no
titties are pectoral are titties no
they're mamories mamories this that's
like saying American Gladiators had big
titties they didn't turbo
did 30 minute somebody's going to
eventually need to add a vagina but
we're not there yet all right we're not
there yet it's a digital Nomad that's a
gorilla right now okay we're we're
playing the gender neutral game so
everybody's relatable we want our fans
go ahead go ahead go ahead okay so
gender neutral for now [__] Cooks
like the best oh [__] come on I love
food debl eggs me love food we're to say
all the bomb [__] cooking digital Nomad
me love food M that's great
conversationalist this is the most
boring Joe I've ever [__] see in my
life of all the [__] things you don't
you don't see it but I do okay
conversation I like I like
conversation I like conversation so do I
yeah right I like good conversation you
got to have someone that you can enjoy
the visuals but it's the inside that me
like dude [__] tastes great so when I'm
eating her out that's true no it was an
excellent choice it is a very good one
you could change the flavor of [__] [__]
but you cannot change the brains of the
person giving you head for five minutes
this this is a
must enjoys watching 8s movies ooh I
like those are great movies yeah that's
sick there's nothing wrong with that
there nothing wrong with that 80s that
was a good
ERA yeah they might not even be born by
that time but still yeah it's a good ERA
oh they definitely won't be one that
time oh no no has a
very you're always right
attitude I like that you deny
yeah she gaslights herself you know what
I mean I have to say I have to vote
against this yeah I I get so bored when
someone agrees with me too AR it's too I
think it's dangerous for me to always be
right I agree I agree I agree I agree
agree agree age I need ball busters yeah
yeah you need a little bit of that
friction I think if I was always right I
I would we would be screwed oh [__] I
don't make good decisions that's true
that's true somebody who is have to go
oh you guys denied huh yeah you got two
denied now you don't get another I'm not
good at picking these people somebody
who is adventurous and willing to try
new things mm in the bedroom no just
in only if it don't
hurt I agree yeah agreed yeah yep yep
yep tightest little [__] [__] oh
yeah ding ding
ding no I don't I I like what hasn't
been checked off yet oh yeah there it is
actually I yeah there it is
no Ian I get it I get it I get it but I
don't I don't I don't no no no I um I
prefer lose I prefer lose I'm sorry what
do you mean I want to last longer it's
too tight every time it's like I got
pick for prices
right yeah I I I I reject I it's too
tight I can't last it's I rather have
loose and it's all about the long all
for it it's all about the long game yeah
I like a l i like a loose puss over
Joe everyone was so excited Joe come on
SI yeah you could just say loose ass
when it's your turn then you have that
too well I mean no because you guys are
going for the super ficial and I'm more
of a real like I'm looking like at this
as like a long-term marriage material
that's so sweet all right it's my turn
um loves to play games video and regular
games and is competitive but for some
reason 51% of the time I win oh 51
that's like Blackjack odds just 51% yeah
okay okay yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
cool that's cool that's cool that's cool
definitely losing 49% of the time not
bad all all not bad bad that's cool
that's cool that's cool
um someone with a good family they're
really close to their family and their
family's really good what the [__] is
this yeah I know I agree though I like
it definitely designing this person but
yeah they got a family I guess they have
a really good family that's sweet man
strong strong family connection and then
they're like really nice to their
parents and they get along and Hell Rich
siblings inherit hell money yeah but not
too not too rich like I want them to be
like recently cuz they remember that
they used to be broke and their dad had
to [__] beg and they ate cans of like
corn for dinner or something she wanted
new money type yeah but then like so so
they appreciate that [__] but they know
how to have a good time you know and all
their sisters are just as hot and
they're down hell yeah hell
yeah no cuz I can't [__] them oh no you
said anything about that yeah but what's
the point of
having Temptation what's the point
having wallpaper my
friend it's nice to look at it's nice to
look at that is that is I want I want uh
to add but nobody voted they do you want
or you want a shitty family I thought we
all voted we all voted we good family
good family no cuz some people be like I
want her to have a shitty family so she
could come to me and be like oh I want
to be a part no no no no I want good
family okay I just want to make sure you
guys wer like
that good we agree we agree I want I
want her to have no allergies ooh that's
a good one nobody wants a bad DNA
because when your partner has bad
allergies you also technically have them
in the way that like you have to look
out for everything they need to look out
nck has allergies is so [__] annoying
yeah like peanuts got to be off
everything you can't eat at certain
places you know they they can do that
one thing where like one eye looks over
here and the other one can see what's
going on over
there why for surveillance for
surveillance no no this is trying to
create us that's like having a [__]
surveillance robot in your house that
has a gun and you could shoot you no
like you're talking what if there bad
guys and they can like like one's like
still talking to you but they could see
like what's going on that could be used
against you bar how you're you're
checking out the wallpaper checking out
the wallpaper and she sees that [__] out
the back of her eye you're not thinking
these things through dude no I'm still
thinking survival it's like having a
ring camera the ey things what do you
guys think you guys agree no um I would
agree if like I don't look at her and
she's like [__] this sometimes no she
has the ability to
control she has the ability to do like
she's just looking normal but like also
can be aware of stuff going on like the
ability to control it but if you can do
that why wouldn't you always be doing
that because sometimes you're so locked
in into the conversation that she's look
into both of your eyes no no
cuz she's a good conversationalist oh
yeah mhm okay agree everyone agree thank
you
go look at
the um somebody who has a great sense of
humor but in particular somebody who is
sarcastic sarcastic so dark humor
sarcasm sarcastic very important to me
sarcastic yeah it's but not not towards
me MH don't make fun of me no no no yeah
not towards me all for it oh 1,000% [__]
yeah you have to it's a it's a sign of
saying you're [__] smart without
saying that you're smart cuz if you
could get it and you can play that game
on a different level then you're not a
[__] just a face value idiot yeah
there's layers to the conversation yeah
you should have joke about this it's too
sacred shut the [__] that's great as
sarcasm though yeah
yeah total [__] milth oh oh I agree
that's hot I agree ding ding ding mil
Tas not right now but in the future yeah
in the future yeah not right now no
comes out milk comes out milk with no
children though act one milk with no
children okay that's even hotter oh like
has the milk
essence or she's that perfect age where
she can't get pregnant what age is that
that menopause age no not the milk age
not
that
you not know yeah what's that the no
condom age yeah but no but but we we
just rather have birth
control we don't need her yeah but then
what if it she can't have healthy kids
cuz birth control we don't need like her
to have a hysterctomy Joe
okay I don't know I just thought it
might be more convenient so then she
didn't have to damage her body she's
just milfy looking she just milky
looking milfy looking or a mil total mil
total [__] mil is what I said total
milk all in favor yes yeah why not all
right de deal for you de for for you
Dill for
you D for
you we voted you a dill be happy about
it I'm not happy about it some DS are
hotter than mils too that's what we're
yeah but can it still work all right uh
pristine sense very good sense of style
fashion and taste o she got good taste
from interior design to dressing to
recommendations even for me on what to
like wear if it's like dope or whatnot
you're looking for the perfect person
that one mine that's a perfect woman
right there like I like I'm trashy does
that include she can knowing when to be
trashy cuz she's doing it for you dude
being trash is an art too yeah I I'm
really good at that yeah yeah
you yeah yeah you are all in favor yes
fashion there's something very hot about
fashion like it's like you're so ugly
without clothes but when you put it on
wow there's something about it man I
will'll finish off with your your two
suggestions go
ahead uh someone that has wait wait wait
you should go last I feel like you're
last guy right cuz mine's very mid
mine's mid I think Joe's going to be mid
no I let's hope it's not mine is I want
she has to be the type of person that
treats service industry people very well
that's that's really that's a that's I
want that in my mil that's some
Cinderella [__] no I want her to spit at
them
whoa guys vote harder vote harder punch
down I want a cerella nice person with
the smallest little vagina that's
amazing I don't think she means our deal
for you D thank you all right the final
trait by Joe Jitsu all right so I like
girls that have good social skills but
especially ones that uh when you get a
[__] they
go he's back he's
back get over here Steve give this man a
hug I knew it I knew he was still in
there I knew he was still in there I
knew
it that's a social
skill